[Music]
a million dollar garage weird rivalries
and who are we fighting anyway you might
feel a need for speed after watching the
top gun movies but you'll also be left
with more questions than answers
integral to the ethos of the top gun
movies and the top gun school is the
idea that these pilot trainees are the
best of the best it's where the top one
percent of new pilots go to study the
most advanced flying maneuvers but at
the end of top gun a few of our brand
new class of graduates are called away
urgently for a crisis situation in top
gun maverick the entire movie is based
around teaching recent topkin grads to
fly a dangerous urgent assignment to
destroy a nuclear facility in both
situations it's impossible not to wonder
are there no more experienced pilots
available the elder maverick ends up
leading the mission himself in top gun
maverick of course but are there no
other veterans out there with any chops
at all in the first top gun the cadets
don't even have time to enjoy their
graduation banquet the plot intervenes
to place them in a deadly situation that
just doesn't seem like an actual
entry-level assignment even for the best
of the best
the most cognitively dissonant part of
the first top gun is the relationship
between our protagonist maverick and his
archrival iceman if you just read the
dialogue in the scenes you might assume
iceman is actually the lead role because
every single thing he sneers at his
reckless nemesis is actually just a very
sensible thing to point out iceman is
described as a talented and polished
pilot and he points out multiple times
that maverick acts irresponsibly by
defying protocol and taking needless
risks the way the scenes are acted and
the tension that val kilmer and tom
cruise capably bring to their roles make
you more likely to root for maverick
just out of movie watching habit why is
this blonde jerk being so snide to our
hero the thing is iceman is right
maverick is talented but pure chaos and
even his superiors admit that they have
grave doubts about how his attitude will
translate to combat maverick even
indirectly gets goose killed and iceman
takes the high road and offers his
sympathy instead of saying i told you so
mitchell
i'm sorry about goose
at the end of top gun maverick saves
iceman's life in combat and they become
lifelong friends so all's well that ends
well but no one brings up that maverick
learned nothing he ignored iceman's
level-headed and reasonable advice and
it all just kind of worked out for the
best in spite of him
any moviegoer that seen a war movie is
familiar with the iconography of
military dog tags in countless scenes
they recovered from the fallen as a
symbolic gesture of carrying the memory
of their service and in due course
passed on to the soldiers next of kin
why then in top gun does maverick keep
goose's dog tags instead of giving them
to his widow at first distraught as he
is with grief it's understandable that
he would hold on to them as he pondered
whether to continue his career as a
pilot but ultimately after the big
climactic dogfight maverick
cathartically throws them into the ocean
ensuring goose's family will never get
them it could be argued that this is in
keeping with mavericks rather
self-centered nature but topkin lets us
know with the score and general tone of
the scene that it considers this a
meaningful thoughtful moment
maverick's appeal in both top gun movies
is a self-fulfilling paradox he's the
main character and beautiful women are
drawn to him so presumably he must be
charming but that doesn't hold up when
you watch his actual interactions with
charlie blackwood played by kelly
mcgillis in top gun first after a mildly
amusing but also embarrassing impromptu
karaoke session he follows her into the
women's bathroom to make a fool of
himself and aggressively hits on her
instead of being even momentarily cowed
or apologetic when he realizes she's
actually a top gun instructor maverick
interrupts her presentation and
embarrasses her again in front of all
the other recruits there is some vague
pillow talk about how she's impressed by
his flying skills and wants to hear more
about the inverted maneuver with an
enemy mig he pulls off in the beginning
of the movie still their romance largely
unfolds with a dreamlike inevitability
it's almost as if they conclude that
they should fall in love just because
they both look like very attractive
movie stars
early in top gun it's insinuated that
maverick has succeeded in spite of the
reputation of his late father himself a
pilot who died during the vietnam war
under mysterious circumstances much like
how he would later work against rooster
in top gun maverick maverick is denied
entry to the naval academy because of
duke mitchell's negative reputation
implying that the military holds grudges
for more than a generation eventually
commander mike viper mitchell reveals to
maverick that his father died a hero his
f1 was hit he was wounded but he could
have made it back he stayed in it saved
three planes before he bought it
this quick explanation raises a
multitude of questions that maverick
doesn't bother to ask how does a wounded
man in a damaged plane save three other
planes viper says it was all covered up
because it happened on the wrong side of
the border but doesn't explain why the
elder mitchell ended up being blamed for
his own death instead of lauded as a
life-saving hero maverick's
surface-level acceptance of a secret
he's waited his entire life to learn
just makes it all the more confusing
top gun maverick trades the shallow
glossy romance of the first movie for a
deeper more lived in love story as he
reconnects with penny benjamin played by
jennifer connelly penny benjamin is
referenced in top gun as the admiral's
daughter that maverick had a dalliance
with among his many other
insubordinations it adds an element of
nostalgic sweetness as the characters
bond over paternal struggles bit by bit
it's revealed or implied that penny and
maverick have gotten together and split
up several times over the years indeed
if they first became involved before the
events shown in top gun by the time top
gun maverick takes place they've been on
again off again for nearly four decades
penny's daughter even somewhat coldly
warns maverick not to break her mother's
heart again though the actors have
chemistry the vague references they make
to a shared past doesn't really seem to
reflect the actual amount of time that
the characters have known one another
they pick up where they left off
entirely too easily and never have to
hash out what drove them apart in the
past at any length or in any depth
the biggest gaping hole in the
screenplay of both top gun movies is the
identity of the ever mysterious enemy
devotees and armchair sleuths have
various explanations for both movies in
short based on a few clues it's likely
either russia or china in top gun and
could more or less only be iran in top
gun maverick but the movies themselves
dance around the topic with an unsubtle
deliberateness that requires us as
viewers to just quiet down the basic
deductive parts of our brain in top gun
the enemy is only represented by a few
mig fighters seen in action sequences so
you don't have much time to wonder about
their point of origin but in top gun
maverick we see extensive clear footage
of the enemy nation's fifth generation
advanced fighter jets the pilots of
which wear conveniently tinted visors
later maverick and rooster run onto an
enemy airfield and steal one of their
planes all without catching a glimpse of
a human face or any kind of telltale
flag or insignia
ultimately neither top gun movie can
afford to identify the enemy nation
involved because to do so would risk
inflaming international tensions in the
actual world and raised impossible
questions to answer in their fictional
one namely wouldn't the climax of both
movies rise to the level of an incident
that could incite world war 3 in top gun
set in the waning days of the cold war
shooting down a few mig fighters could
perhaps be reasonably settled with
whatever country they came from without
further escalation it's top gun maverick
that truly makes no sense the nation
that america is so keen to prevent from
enriching uranium may not have nuclear
capability just yet but it has
sophisticated surface-to-air missiles
they also have fifth generation fighter
planes that are superior to what
maverick and co are flying such a nation
would definitely have long-range
missiles that would lay waste to our
heroes entire aircraft carrier more or
less immediately after the mission and
presumably incite all-out war from there
the years have apparently been very kind
to pete maverick mitchell between top
gun and top gun maverick he barely looks
any older he still gets to fly planes
and he's stretched every penny of his
captain's salary to the limit as he owns
two absurdly expensive vehicles as does
his love interest penny benjamin
mav has his own personal hanger with a
vintage p51 plane worth 4.5 million
dollars as well as a vintage green aston
martin worth more than 22 million
dollars not to be outdone the bar that
penny owns is either
incomprehensibly successful or her
admiral father has helped her out
considerably she owns a sailboat valued
at more than 300 thousand dollars and
shows up at the end of the movie in a
porsche worth 181 thousand dollars
maverick must have a type in the
original top gun his love interest
charlie drove a similarly priced black
porsche speedster as well it's hard not
to wonder how do all these characters
afford such expensive vehicles
just want to manage expectations
[Music]